at time t is greater than or equal to
zero a particle moving along a curve in
the x y plane has position
x of t and y of t so its x coordinate is
given by the parametric function x of t
and y coordinate by the parametric
function y of t
with velocity vector v of t is equal to
and the x component of the velocity
vector is cosine of t squared and the y
component of the velocity vector is e to
the 0.5 t
at t equals 1 the particle is at the
point three comma five
is that the point three comma five all
right
find the x coordinate of the position of
the particle
at time t is equal to two
all right so how do we think about this
well you could view the x-coordinate at
time t equals 2. so let's say
so we could say x
at time 2 which they don't give it they
don't give that to us directly
but we could say that's going to be x of
x of 1
plus
some change in x as we go from t equals
1 to t equals 2. but what is this going
to be
well we know what the velocity is and so
the velocity especially the x component
we can really focus on the x component
for this first part because we only want
to know the x coordinate of the position
of the particle
well we know we're going we know the the
x component of velocity as a function of
t is cosine
of t
cosine of t squared
and if you take your velocity in a
certain dimension and then multiply it
times a very small change in time
in a very small change in time dt this
would give you your very small change in
x if you multiply velocity times change
in time it'll give you a it'll give you
a displacement but what we can do is we
can sum up all of the changes in time
from
t equals 1 to t equals 2. remember this
is the change in x
from
from t equals 1
to
t is equal to 2. so what we have right
over here we can say that x of 2 which
is what we're trying to solve
is going to be x of 1 and they give that
at time equals 1 the particle is at the
point 3 comma 5. its x coordinate is 3.
so this this right over here is 3
and then our change in x from t equals 1
to t equals 2 is going to be this
integral the integral from t equals 1 to
t equals 2 of cosine
of t squared
dt and just to make sure we understand
what's going on here remember how much
how much are we moving over a very small
dt well you take your velocity in that
dimension times dt it'll give you a
displacement in that dimension and then
we sum them all up from t equals one to
t equals two
and in this part of the ap test we are
allowed to use calculators and so let's
use one
all right
so there's my calculator
and i can evaluate so let's see i want
to evaluate 3
plus the definite integral i click on
math
and then i can scroll down
to function integral
right there the definite integral of
and i make sure i'm in radian mode that
which that's what you should assume
so cosine unless they tell you otherwise
cosine of t squared now i'll use x as my
variable of integration so i'll say
cosine of x cosine of x squared
and then my variable of integration is x
so i'm really integrating cosine of x
squared dx but it'll give the same value
comma
from 1
until 2
and now i'll let the calculator munch on
it a little bit and i get approximately
2.557
so this is approximately 2.55
2.557 did i let me make sure that i
added the three yeah three plus that
definite integral from one to two two
point five five
seven and i just rounded that so there
you go